the daring rescue in Indiana just days
after giving birth to her own miracle
baby
a new mother rushes to help save a truck
driver from this massive tanker fire
Adriana Diaz spoke with the fearless mom
when Holly McNally saw the wall of
flames
she ran toward it and I saw him coming
out of the huge plume of smoke with fire
coming off of his head and his back but
he had nothing left on invisible the
fire had burned his clothes everything
and I said what's hitting my feet he
said jet fuel and at that point I said
oh my gosh you guys we have got to
hustle because this fire is gonna follow
us what made you run toward danger I
mean everybody else was staying back and
maternal instinct McNally had just given
birth to her fourth child five days ago
a son named Connor trooper Chris Hanson
arrived as McNally and two other good
Samaritans were dragging the driver away
just before a second explosion three
selfless people took enough initiative
to say this not today not not on our
watch what are you gonna tell your baby
boy when he grows up but mommy was tough
that day and he was my driving force to
save a life plus get back to him tell
her mommy was a hero I said that's what
I'll tell her myself I said to be proud
proud because she risked her life to
save a stranger for CBS this morning
Saturday Adriana Diaz Indianapolis I
love that things like this can establish
connections with people that can last a
lifetime I mean he said hey I'm gonna
tell your kid what a hero is mom there's
a powerful mama bear
[Laughter]